[Música]
bienvenidos a áfrica siete días un
magazine informativo de llegado al
continente africano comenzamos con los
titulares en marruecos una operación
policial causó la muerte de decenas de
migrantes que intentaban entrar a la
ciudad española de melilla el presidente
del gobierno español elogió la actuación
de las autoridades marroquíes lo que
reabrió el debate sobre la violencia
contra los migrantes en las fronteras
europeas
un diente de patrice lumumba héroe de la
independencia del congo el único resto
encontrado desde su asesinato en
1961 volvió a la república democrática
del congo para tener por fin una
sepultura repasamos la vida de lumumba y
las condiciones de su asesinato y nos
dirigimos a nigeria donde una escuela de
cine gratuita forma a guionistas
directores y actores con el objetivo de
hacer llegar a nollywood a la industria
cinematográfica nigeriana a todo el
mundo a través de las plataformas de
streaming
este viernes 24 de junio decenas de
personas murieron como consecuencia de
un operativo policial de las autoridades
de españa y marruecos que pretendían
impedirles el paso desde este país hasta
el enclave español de melilla
esta ciudad está rodeada de altas vallas
que delimitan la separación terrestre
entre el territorio europeo y africano
por lo que la frontera está controlada
por un lado por la policía española y
del otro lado por la marroquí
las impactantes imágenes de una multitud
de cuerpos amontonados sin recibir
auxilio en las calles de la ciudad
marroquí de nador se realizaron causando
indignación es redes sociales el rechazo
ante lo ocurrido aumentó otras las
palabras del presidente del gobierno
español pedro sánchez que elogió la
actuación de la policía de ambos países
la violencia causada por el operativo
reabrió el debate sobre la
externalización de las fronteras euros
es decir en cargar y financiar a
terceros países como marruecos para que
impidan a los migrantes y refugiados
acceder a territorio europeo
escuchemos a nuestra corresponsal sufría
català sobre lo ocurrido en nador
si las autoridades de marruecos han
confirmado la muerte de 23 personas
migrantes pero la asociación marroquí de
derechos humanos ha podido documentar 37
fallecidos entre los que habría también
dos agentes de policía de marruecos
también seguiría habiendo decenas de
heridos de gravedad y según la versión
policial los migrantes murieron
asfixiados en una avalancha en la parte
marroquí de la frontera de melilla tras
duros enfrentamientos con la policía en
las imágenes que se han difundido se
puede apreciar que las fuerzas
marroquíes emplearon una violencia
brutal contra los migrantes y ahora la
asociación marroquí de derechos humanos
y otros colectivos exigen que se abra
una investigación para aclarar lo
ocurrido también se han podido
documentar fosas en la ciudad marroquí
de nador donde las autoridades de
marruecos tendrían la intención de
enterrar a los muertos en la frontera
sin identificar los cuerpos ni hacer
autopsia lo que significaría que las
familias de las víctimas no tendrían
acceso a los sistemas de justicia
también fuentes sobre el terreno nos
cuentan que en la ciudad de nador las
comunidades migrantes estarían viviendo
una situación de auténtico pánico nos
dicen que no se atreven a salir a la
calle por miedo a represalias y tan solo
a ir al hospital por miedo a ser
deportadas o desplazadas de forma
forzada lejos de la frontera y es que
este nuevo episodio de muerte en la
frontera de melilla y llegan un contexto
de incremento de la represión hacia
migrantes y refugiados aquí en marruecos
como consecuencia de la externalización
de políticas migratorias de la unión
europea cabe recordar que tanto españa
como bruselas pagan cantidades
millonarias anualmente a marruecos para
que impida por todos los medios que
estas personas migrantes y refugiadas se
acerquen a la frontera española y los
colectivos de defensa de derechos
humanos sobre el terreno llevan semanas
alertando de que la tensión no deja de
crecer y también denuncian que la
violencia en esta frontera euro africana
no ha hecho más que aumentar desde que
españa y marruecos se resolvieran en
abril la que fue su mayor crisis
diplomática en 20 años
el lunes 20 de junio las autoridades
belgas se entregaron el diente de
patrice lumumba a las autoridades
congoleñas en presencia de los hijos del
dirigente asesinado
la pieza contenida en una caja fue
colocada en un ataúd para ser enterrada
en la república democrática del congo en
el siguiente informe les propongo
repasar la vida y las circunstancias del
asesinato de patrice lumumba
patrice emery lumumba nació el 2 de
julio de 1925 en el centro de lo que
entonces era el congo belga como
estudiante con capacidades intelectuales
superiores a la media recibió una
educación sólida más tarde su carisma su
elocuencia y sus convicciones
nacionalistas le llevaron a liderar el
movimiento nacionalista congoleño un
partido de inspiración
panafricanista que fundó en
1958 en enero de 1960 asistió a la
conferencia de bruselas con el objetivo
de coordinar una fecha para la
independencia del congo belga en las
elecciones que siguieron el éxito de su
partido permitió a patrice lumumba a
convertirse en el primer primer ministro
del congo independiente pero fue el 30
de junio de 1960 cuando escribió una de
las páginas más importantes de la
historia de la resistencia al
colonialismo con un discurso de crítica
al racismo de los colonos en presencia
del rey belga padua
en grasa
xy se anillan de sangre
tienes demasiado atrás
los comités de 3er
pensamos con el estirón y
desde el sur
de eso
enfadado por el discurso de patrice
lumumba el rey belga sólo tenía una
obsesión acabar con él yendo el 5 de
septiembre del mismo año el líder
congoleño fue destituido bajo presión
belga y hecho prisionero
unos meses más tarde es fue en el
extremo sur del combo en katanga donde
se jugó el destino de la nueva nación
independiente el 17 de enero de 1961
hacia las 11 de la noche
lumumba fue asesinado después de haber
sido torturado durante semanas el 21 de
enero su cuerpo y los dedos de sus
compañeros fueron desmembrados y
disueltos en ácido sulfúrico un diente
del líder fue guardado por una oficial
belga es esta reliquia que 60 años
después se entregará a la familia del
héroe de la independencia
los líderes de los países de la
comunidad de áfrica oriental se
reunieron el lunes 20 de junio en
nairobi la capital de kenia para debatir
la situación de seguridad en el este de
la república democrática del congo
allí acordaron crear una fuerza militar
regional para tratar de poner fin al
conflicto marc janko de nuestra
corresponsal él tiene los detalles según
la presión sea congoleña esta fuerza
regional estará bajo el mando militar de
kenia debería ser operativo y las
próximas semanas y no incluir elementos
del ejército ruandés el presidente de la
república democrática del congo ya había
indicado en varias ocasiones que no
quería a wanda en esta fuerza ya que
acusa a su vecino de apoyar a los
rebeldes del 23 que se han enfrentado al
ejército congoleño en el este del país
este es algo que querer y siempre ha
negado la comunicado emitida por la
presidencia keniana es más general
indica que los jefes de la comunidad de
áfrica oriental han adoptado una serie
de medidas que determinan el estatuto y
la estructura de la futura fuerza sus
misiones y la distribución geográfica de
sus efectivos pero sin dar más detalles
siempre según la presidencia keniana los
jefes y estado pidieron un alto al fuego
inmediato a los grupos rebeldes y la
retirada a las posiciones tomadas
recientemente es para concluir los jefe
de estado también pidieron que se
pusiera fin a la incitación al odio en
los últimos días varias voces han
expresado su preocupación por el aumento
de las llamamientos a la violencia
contra las comunidades wanda zonas que
viven en la república democrática del
congo
seguimos hablando de urban da porque en
la cumbre de jefes de gobierno de la
commonwealth el primer ministro
británico boris johnson defendió su plan
de deportar a territorio ruandés a los
solicitantes de asilo que llegan a reino
unido por el canal de la mancha
escuchemos al primer ministro británico
peace
that is apps este es un plan que creo
que es absolutamente necesario para
solucionar el problema del tráfico
ilegal a través del canal de la mancha
de personas cuyas vidas están siendo
puestas en peligro por bandas y hay que
romper el modelo de negocio de estas
bandas esto es lo correcto y creo que lo
que la gente tiene que entender lo que
los críticos de esta política tienen que
entender y he estado escuchando montones
y montones de críticas es que ruanda se
ha transformado completamente en las
últimas dos décadas making the lost
acapulco
y vamos a hablar ahora de cultura en
particular de la industria
cinematográfica de nigeria llamada
hollywood en lagos el gobierno nigeriano
le apuesta cada vez más a invertir en
educación del séptimo arte
para su juventud una industria que día a
día le aporta a la economía nacional de
este país africano y toca las puertas de
grandes plataformas de streaming veamos
el informe de juan pabló lucumí
luces cámaras y acción
todo está listo para rodar una de las
producciones seleccionadas como su
trabajo de grado de este pequeño grupo
de jóvenes cineastas que se preparan
para hacer producciones locales que
pasen fronteras desde lagos la capital
de nigeria para el mundo el objetivo es
contar historias africanas pero con una
mirada internacional llegar a grandes
plataformas como netflix y amazon y
aportar a la narrativa de la diáspora
africana
hice un par de cortometrajes pero sabía
que tenía que entender más sobre el cine
y apareció la academia creativa ebony
live la solicité vine a la entrevista y
me seleccionaron ahora veo el cine desde
una perspectiva diferente y entiendo
realmente de qué se trata todo este
mundo del cine
de los 500 aspirantes que se postulan
para el programa de cine auspiciado por
el gobierno nigeriano sólo 120 obtienen
el puesto el programa de aprendizaje es
intenso los estudiantes que logran
ingresar al curso deben especializarse
en temas de postproducción iluminación
sonido y escritura de guiones los
maestros son de sudáfrica kenia y por
supuesto nigeria un país en donde el
gobierno le apuesta cada vez más a esta
industria y que desde ya empieza a ver
los resultados
netflix arnold habla con salones
expuestos su contentillo no creo que lo
que netflix y todas esas otras
plataformas han hecho es exponernos a
contenidos más allá de una región
concreta tenemos contenidos de india
corea del sur de europa y tenemos
algunos de américa del sur esto hace que
muchos nigerianos se den cuenta de que
sus historias pueden ser vistas a escala
mundial
el año pasado la industria
cinematográfica representó el 23 por
ciento del pib de nigeria es decir más
de 660 millones de dólares lo que
posiciona a nollywood como potencia
cultural en el continente africano
es todo por esta semana en áfrica siete
días gracias por acompañarnos la
información continúa en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]